a random black man who was according to
some out for a jog has been shot dead by
two white men who chased after him
claiming he looked like a burglar that
had been in the neighborhood the story
is a tragedy and there have been no
arrests at this point in time now I'm
not pretending to know everything about
the story I'm gonna tell you what we
believe is the case so far
Ahmad R burry 25 years old this happened
February 23rd it's been months in
Brunswick Georgia the video has recently
been released our burry was running
through the settle assures neighborhood
he was chased by 64 year old Gregory
McMichael and his 34 year old son Travis
McMichael now I'm gonna play some of the
video for you a part of a video of part
of the incident for you it is relatively
graphic heads-up in case you want to
skip ahead it's about 30 35 seconds of
video you're listening and not watching
you'll be able to see the video on our
YouTube clip or find it elsewhere online
very easily let's take a look
no one has yet been arrested for this
although it has been more than two
months since the incident took place so
here's the story as it has now been
pieced together and it is certainly not
a complete story
to date the McMichaels father and son
they saw our burry as they claim quote
hauling ass that's the term they used
and they thought that must be the
burglar who's been burglarizing houses
in this neighborhood
so the McMichaels grabbed a 357 Magnum
and a shotgun
one for each got into their pickup truck
and started chasing a mod our burry a
third man also joined the chase in their
pickup truck they caught up to our burry
and Gregory McMichael reportedly shouted
at him to stop and this created a
confrontation of sorts McMichael claims
our burry started attacking his son
Travis a scuffle ensued potentially over
control of the shotgun that Travis
McMichael had which led to a shot being
fired and subsequently a second shot
being fired
our burry did not have a weapon and he
was shot dead at the scene now the next
step would be according to officials for
this to go to a grand jury but it's
important to understand that it's not
necessary to wait for a grand jury to
make arrests and we're gonna talk about
that in a moment we have a statement
from director Vic Reynolds of the
Georgia Bureau of Investigations of the
Georgia Bureau of Investigation and he
talks about the case and listened to the
hemming and hawing that's going on here
I offered our assistance in this matter
mr. Durden and I were able to connect
and speak about 9:30 last night and he
quickly accepted our offer and asked us
to become involved in the case some of
you may not realize but the GBI can only
become involved in a matter when asked
by the local authorities after mr.
Dern's request last night I advised him
that we would hit the ground running
this morning we've now assigned this
case to three of our experienced
supervisory level agents they come from
two separate regions and a specialized
unit which is located in the third
region we've also decided that this case
we'll be ran from headquarters that will
bring to bear every resource and all the
experience this agency has in resolving
this matter you know our goal in every
investigation is to seek the truth so
listen guys this is on video now I admit
the video doesn't show us the start of
the incident and I'm going to talk about
that in a moment but it's been months a
lot of it is on video this is a huge dog
and pony show now why have there not
been any arrests I'm going to do the
best job I can at laying out the case
for not arresting anyone yet okay now I
want to be really clear disclaimers I'm
not saying this case that I'm in about
to I'm about to lay out resonates with
me I'm gonna make the strongest case I
can to play devil's advocate okay the
McMichaels were legally carrying their
guns the 357 Magnum and the shotgun were
legally open carried based on Georgia
law so having the guns with them is not
legally a problem they begin to pursue
someone that they believe to be a
burglary suspect now you and I might say
listen this resembles a burglary suspect
it was just a guy who happened to be
black that this is racism there's race
that explains what went on here that's
fine it is still not illegal to pursue
someone again under Georgia law who they
believe to be a burglary suspect now you
and I understand that this term burglary
suspect is absolutely crazy we're just
talking about a guy who happens to be
black but I'm trying to lay out a legal
case here so we can see both sides of
this Georgia law says a private person
may arrest an offender if the offense is
committed in the presence or with an
immediate knowledge the video starts
during a confrontation where there is
already a scuffle between our burry and
one of the McMichaels now again under
Georgia law if indeed our burry was
attacking or trying to take the gun from
McMichael McMichael would be allowed to
use up to deadly force in that situation
now the video starts too late to see how
this all started
we don't have the story of the dead guy
we only have the story of
McMichaels who of course don't want to
be arrested and charged here now I want
to be really clear I believe that these
two should have been arrested and then
let the legal system work what what I'm
pointing out is that there is a case
some are making for why it's logical
that nobody has been arrested yet but I
have a different perspective we have a
system of justice people are innocent
until proven guilty I'm not saying
anything about the legal guilt of the
McMichaels that would be for a court
sort out what I am saying is that this
is clearly meeting the standard for it
to be in the legal system
if the racial circumstances were
reversed if this were two black men with
guns or three men in a pickup truck who
identified a guy that resembled the
burglar only in that he was white and
the burglar was believed to be white the
two or three black men would have been
arrested and charged and it would be up
to them to mount a legal defense at this
point they might be guilty legally they
might be not guilty legally it would be
up to the state to prove it in a court
of law but they would have been arrested
and charged by now in this case it's
been more than two months
no one's been arrested merely on the say
that the victim resembled a possible
burglar in that he was black this is
laughable now again you don't have to
take a position on guilt or innocence to
critique the situation you have people
on the right saying the McMichaels have
the presumption of innocence until
proven guilty and that is exactly right
they do there is no argument for me on
that but nothing has happened to even
put them in a position of being tried
and that is what doesn't make sense when
you think about how this would have gone
down if the circumstances were only
slightly different if you disagree with
me if I'm missing something by all means
let me know I want to get it right
that's what matters I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman quick break right back after this
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blink it's
blink Isleta consume an entire book on
your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important core ideas and
information from that book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do or if you
just want to sample a book before you
buy the entire thing I recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great Stephen Hawking this is a book
that I have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on blink
Asst blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video